(audience cheering)
- We are back
and you have seen it
happen from time to time.
Here on this show, I get
to talking with guests
and the conversations go along
'cause mama likes to talk.
That's why we keep a vault of interviews
we couldn't fit in the original show,
but we want to make sure
that you don't miss.
Today's Kelly Extra takes
us back to September
when we had Scarlett Johansson here.
We got to talking about our kids and one
of the cardinal Marvel Universe rules
she said she would never break.
Check it out.
When Jeremy Renner was
here, he was talking
about how he used his Hawkeye
costume for Halloween.
Have you ever done that?
- What?
- You never done that?
I would totally do that.
- That's allowed?
Marvel never told me I could do that.
- I don't, I feel like Jeremy maybe says,
sorry doesn't ask permission.
- Yeah.
- Maybe he's
one of those people.
- You're actually right.
That's definitely...
- I'm one of those people.
So yeah, 'cause then you
can always say sorry later.
- I get it.
- I would totally do it.
- I'm not, I am very by the books.
I don't, I am the person that is,
I don't wanna be, I'm constantly,
I worked for Marvel for 10 years
and I was constantly
terrified I was going to
spoil some major-
- spoil something?
- anything from the color of my,
that it's like now a darker shade of Navy
it was like, you can't say a thing.
- Oh, wow.
I'm sort of programmed to never-
- Sounds a little abusive, but yeah,
you're programmed. (laughs)
- Sorry
please. Yeah
- I would, I don't do well with secrets
or anything like that
so I would hate that.
Having to keep a secret.
I don't know.
- There was definitely
cast members like, you know
- That are like me?
Yeah. That are really, really bad at it
that are like a liability.
- I call it passion.
We're just excited
about something so that's why
we give it away an accident.
But the, you said 10 years
and this is like the 10th anniversary of
the first Marvel movie coming out.
So like or Avengers movie coming out.
So what do you remember
like what's one of your favorite ones?
Like, of being a part of it?
- I mean, because
- It seems like such a fun set.
- It's, they're all, yeah.
I've had the most fun on
the, on the Marvel movies.
Just 'cuz you have a whole family
there that you come back to.
- Yeah.
- Every, you know, year
and a half or whatever.
And so, you know, it's been
an adjustment not having
you know, my, my peeps around like that.
Yeah. I would say, you
know, the first Avengers was
amazing just because it was
such a, you felt it was just
like Wild West
and not that genre had not
been, you know, it was, it was
- Not just quite established
- Quite established like that.
Yeah. It wasn't established
exactly in the same way.
And so it felt like we were doing some
we didn't know if it was
gonna work and you know
just kind of felt like a crazy thing.
It worked, turn out
- It worked for all the crazies
like me, like I am obsessed.
I love them.